if you want to hear how the mythological
monster the Windigo from the Pet
Sematary novel was hidden throughout
this movie then stick around to the end
of this video the opening of Mary
Lambert's 1989 adaptation of Pet
Sematary contains a montage of kids over
the years laying their pets down to rest
in the pet cemetery and this scene
contains a lot of Easter eggs
referencing some of the pets
memorialized in the cemetery in King's
novel for example we hear a young judge
saying goodbye to his dog spots and see
the grave which was carved by mr. Judson
Crandall there are also grave markers
for Hannah who was regarded as the best
dog that ever lived the book mentions
Hannah died in 1939 making this one of
the oldest readable grave markers one of
the more recent ones was biffer which
you can see right here smokey the cat is
another pet that was mentioned in the
book but smokey was actually the real
world cat that belong to Stephen King's
daughter Naomi and the cat was struck
down by a truck in orient in Maine
a short time after Kings son Owen had a
close call with another truck on that
road and the incident served as the
inspiration for the novel we're
introduced to the road in the movie with
a shot of a truck barreling over the
camera the low-angle foreshadows the
view that gage might have had during his
final moments
another foreshadowing can be seen in the
bumper sticker on Lewis's car which
reads have you hugged your MD today
which could be a reference to the ending
embrace between Lewis and zombie Rachel
so the cria family moves into their new
home and their daughter Ellie finds the
tire swing as she swings she hears a
creepy sound coming from the forest path
that leads to the pet cemetery
if you haven't read the book this is
easy enough to chalk up to a moose or
something else in the woods but those
familiar with the novel may be reminded
of the Wendigo the Mi'kmaq led instead
to be responsible for souring the earth
upon which the Indian burial ground is
located in the book the Wendy goes power
over the town of Ludlow is talked about
several times and Lewis comes face to
face with the creature when he takes
gauge up to the burial ground
however in this movie the Wendigo is not
mentioned or seen but it is teased at
several more times throughout the film
Ellie's tire swing falls and as Lewis
and Rachel tend to her their son gage
wanders towards the road their new
neighbor and Jud Crandall scoops him up
and gets him to safety the next day the
family gets to unpacking and you can
spot the toy that gage is playing with
is actually a red truck and he crashes
it into a bomb you may also spot that
gage has a whole box of toy trucks which
may explain why he's always wandering
towards the road maybe he just has a
fascination with trucks but that's not
the only thing that causes disaster to
strike the influence of the Wendigo also
plays a part but we'll get back to that
in a little bit as Rachel comes in with
the groceries we meet the caretaker
Missy Dandridge who tells Rachel that
she was lucky to marry a doctor and that
she wishes she had a doctor to help her
with her stomach pains she also mentions
that she's not married and the book
Missy is married to a man named Roger
or possibly David the name erroneously
changes halfway through the book later
that day judge shows them the way to the
pet cemetery Lewis carries gage in the
baby backpack and this would not be the
first time that he carries his son up
that path Rachel is uncomfortable
bringing the kids to the cemetery
because of her aversion to death in the
background you can see the grave marker
for Marla the rabbit these graves just
got to show the level of detail put into
the production design and I thought I'd
point them out because you might not
have picked up on them while watching
the movie before they leave the call of
the one to go can be heard again in the
woods
cuts you the real monster of this story
[Music]
see gauge this is why nobody saved you
when you went out in the road man I'm
going to hell Lewis is leaving for his
first day of work at the University and
his wife comes to say goodbye to him I
think there's something up with the
color yellow foreshadowing death in this
movie not only are Rachel engaged
wearing yellow but the flowers are
yellow the house is yellow and churches
carrying case is yellow so in the scene
everyone who dies in the movie has
yellow on them Missy Dandridge is
sweater isn't yellow but she does have
yellow flowers on her skirt and the
flowers seen later at Memorial are in
fact yellow another interesting note
about the scene is that Rachel
repeatedly calls Lewis dot which makes
sense because he's a doctor but also a
partial reference to Danny's nickname in
the shine
another Stephen King reference can be
spotted in the next scene where this
university student Victor pascal is
brought into Louis's care after being
hit by a truck on the bulletin board
there's a poster warning about rabies in
which a photo of Cujo another Stephen
King adaptation made in the 1980s can be
seen this is more than just a fun
reference though odd actually explains
in the book that rabies is an issue in
Maine and even cites the events of Cujo
taking place a few years prior so
anyways Lewis is unable to save Pascal
because he's basically DOA Lewis gets a
big surprise when Pascale unexpectedly
jumps back to life and tells him the
soil of a man's heart is Stonier this is
a recurring line in the book but what
does it actually mean the full quote in
the book is the soil of a man's heart
Estonia was a man grows what he can and
he tends it stony soil is known to be
harder to grow anything in than fertile
soil he's telling Lewis that the love
that he has for his family cannot be
easily replaced that bringing their
bodies back to life in the burial ground
does not mean they'd be the same people
that Lewis has grown to love Pascal's
ghost comes back that night to try to
warn Lewis to stay away from the mcmac
burial ground who are apparently having
a rave of some sort
Pascal tells Lewis the reason that he
wants to help
because Louis okay I can understand that
line in the book but in the movie he
just takes one look at him and gives up
I mean he puts about as much effort into
saving Pascal as he does that one time
he tried to rake the leaves speaking of
leaves Thanksgiving gets here and the
family goes to visits Rachel's parents
in Chicago while Lewis stays back to
work when he gets a call from Jeff
it's about Ellie's cat Church and he's
fallen victim to the road Judd takes
enough to bury the cat but instead of
stopping at the pet cemetery Lewis
ignores Pascal's warnings and follows
Jutta to the mcmac burial ground a
strange noise is heard nearby this is
perhaps the closest we get to a direct
acknowledgement of the Wendigo but there
are a couple more references later on
when we get to the burial ground an
overhead shot shows that it uses the
same concentric circles layout as the
pet cemetery but not quite as same as
the spiral layout described in the book
Louis Berry's Church and to his dismay
Church returns from the dead only now
with much nastier attitude Louis doesn't
care though as long as he doesn't have
to explain Church his death to Ellie he
goes to meet them at the airport wait
wait a minute did he just pick these
from the noise Darden oh and also these
are yellow flowers meaning someone's
about to die and the winner is it's
missing average why why couldn't she
have married a doctor Rachel stays home
from the funeral with gage still not
able to overcome her fear of death
because of what happened to her sister
Zelda when she was young she totally
misses out though because Stephen King
makes a cameo appearance as the minister
Rachel finally opens up to Lewis about
how her sister suffered from spinal
meningitis and the whole experience was
extremely scarring for her right down to
the creepy painting in her parents house
if you thought that Zelda dying was hard
Rachel oh just Waits because this truck
driver can't control his speed when he's
blasting Sheena is a punk rocker
Ramon the song choice is a little nod to
the use of blitzkrieg bop the Ramon song
that seems to be stuck in Louis's head
all throughout the novel he's constantly
thinking about the lyrics hey let's go
think it's a sign of the town
manipulating him because the lyrics
always seem to pop into his head when
he's thinking of digging up gauge to
move him to the mcmac grounds this is
because the wendi-go has the power to
put those thoughts into Louis's head
because as long as he's in Ludlow as
long as he's close enough to the curse
of ground he remains under its control
remember how I said that gages
fascination with trucks wasn't the only
thing that caused him to wander into the
streets well during what I have come to
call the scene as soon as gage lets go
of the kite a huge gust of wind blows it
into the street and you can actually see
items flying off the picnic table this
is no coincidence it's similar to how in
the book the truck driver says he wasn't
speeding but gets the sudden urge to
drive recklessly as soon as he crosses
over into Ludlow keeping up with the
yellow motif gage Creed's final outfit
is a pair of yellow overall I despite
what I said earlier I actually do feel
bad for him now that I see that he's a
Cubs fan
everybody type F in the comments to pay
your respects to gage
guages casket is decorated with yellow
flowers and things go from worse to even
more worse when Rachel's father starts a
fight with Lewis at the viewing ceremony
after the funeral
Judd realizes that Lewis may be getting
the idea to put gage up in the Mi'kmaq
burial ground so he tells him his story
that he withheld the first time they
went there the story of Timmy Bader man
a man who came back as a monster after
being buried there in the flashback
Timmy Bannerman shouts the phrase love
dead living a reference to the horror
classic Bride of Frankenstein Lewis
sends his family ahead to Chicago once
again claiming that he needs to close
some things up at work but really
plotting to dig up gage and attempt to
revive him at the mcmac grounds he goes
to the cemetery where gage rests in
broad daylight for some reason and pass
cow appears to him standing in front of
a tomb with the name Thomas C far I
almost wonder if the C far is a
reference to Ellie's psychic abilities
like how she has the dream about church
dying and then the dream about Lewis
dying even though she's across the
country when these events take place
also the flowers around gages grave
completely changed from shot to shot
leaving only the yellow flowers Ellie
sees pass cow in her dream and when
Rachel puts two and two together she
senses something is wrong and rushes for
the first flight home to get to Lewis
but not before having another vision of
her sister Zelda
[Music]
good for letting us meanwhile Lewis
takes gages body to the area beyond the
pet cemetery listen to this laughter
heard echoing through the woods
maybe that's actually one of the loons
that Judd had mentioned or it could just
be the ghost of one of the mcmac
tribesmen this is the point at which
Lewis comes face to face with the
Wendigo in the book as I mentioned the
creature doesn't appear in the film but
not showing it is actually very
unsettling because if you are familiar
with the story
you kind of know that it's probably just
off-screen during the scene and I find
that kind of haunting Rachel rents a car
to transport her the final stretch back
home but suddenly blows a tire when she
gets close like the wind that blew the
kite into the road I feel like this tire
popping is no coincidence she ironically
hitches a ride with a Norinco truck
driver however she doesn't realize that
she's actually on the road to her own
death which is reflected in the number
666 on the right side of the truck the
last one to go reference shows up in
Judd krandalls room the wendi-go is
described as being an extremely tall
bipedal creature with the Stags head and
analyzed the candle holder on Judds
mantle takes this form and could
represent the fact that the evil spirit
is now in this room looking at Judd
which it is in the form of gage who's
come back as a zombie and also in the
form of church who distracts Judd before
gage finishes him off with his father's
scalpel have you hugged your MD today
Rachel finally makes it home but the
sound of Zelda's voice sends her into
Judds house instead of her own she goes
up in the judge room where she
hallucinates her son's image to be that
of Zelda when she finally sees gage for
what he is he's wearing the outfit of
the creepy painting in her parents house
the place where she watched her sister
die the outfit on gage and the painting
also matches what Zelda wore on her
deathbed this is in line with the
actions of the stories of those who came
back from the burial ground like Timmy
Bader Mann and Hanratty the bull from
the book the spirit that is taken over
gages body knows the secrets of Rachel's
past and he's using this costume to
bring up the repressed torment of her
childhood she's unable to see past her
son's form however and she becomes his
next victim Lewis wakes up to the sound
of Rachel screams he comes down and sees
the footprints filling him in on what
has happened Rachel's father calls to
make sure that she made it all right and
just as he lied to Ellie after church's
death and told her that the cat was fine
he lies to mr. Goldman and says that
Rachel is still asleep then he gets a
call from gage at judge Randall's house
and realizes that he too has been
possessed by the evil spirits he knows
what he must
the master
[Music]
today is Thanksgiving Day for cat
[Music]
like that
[Applause]
[Music]
so with everyone diet that leaves us
with only two more things you missed
remaining Lewis burns down Judds house
just as Judd burned down the Bader Minh
house to cleanse the evil all of those
years ago but Lewis is deranged at this
point and he believes that if he takes
his late wife to the burial ground right
away that she can still come back normal
to pass the time waiting for her to get
back he plays solitaire on the kitchen
floor
when Rachel arrives he has a jack queen
and the two flipped up to represent
those who died chud Rachel and the
two-year-old gage unfortunately for the
doc Rachel comes back as a zombie and
the movie ends just before she stabs him
in the back
cue the end credits with an original
song by The Ramones as one final
callback to the constant Ramones
references in Stephen King's novel the
song is actually a certifiable BA maybe
one of the last great Ramone songs
actually okay I was listening to that
Ramones song and look what YouTube
decided to autoplay this is savagery
this is pure savagery YouTube so that's
it for the things you missed in the 1989
adaptation of Pet Sematary however for
some reason there's a sequel even though
the book does not have a sequel like at
all and for some other reason that
there's a remake coming out I'll be
covering both of those movies here on
things you missed in the next couple
weeks so remember to subscribe to see
ZZZ world for new Horrors every week
bring that death Bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive